salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
j'espère que vous allez bien aujourd'hui
on a encore des excuses à béziers mais
cette fois je suis votre hôte et paris
avec le nouvel angle j'espère qu'on
retrouve qu'en plein de choses dans
cette excuse qui nous a déjà réservé de
belles surprises
[Musique]
oh
olivier la gestion vous chante
[Musique]
ça regrette que mon premier pied de
biche est dans un sale état mais c'est
un pied de biche un vieux pieds de biche
sûrement bobby biais enfin
[Applaudissements]
j'ai encore fait c'est tout un plastique
quelqu'un sait ce que c'est
ça trouve que c'est cette année et un
truc aussi
sauf si ces lentilles aux 40 et petits
oignons oh oui i will go alors assez le
cadre le cadre de la moto enfin
à
pas
alors et un briquet et un m
d'ailleurs ces lieux je garde michel
il est un peu abîmée mais bon
il ya m
+ 5 m
on va peut-être le garder pour le fun
[Musique]
c'est encore une fois en cure
m
alors je lui
j'aime quand c'est pas déclarent faire
aller moi ça
pense à la mapad motifs proxy philippe
gardent
elle est excellent à en faire
truc qu'est ce que c'est
une serrure
oh
une serrures de porte
une pièce de centimes
rien alors
ah il est beau celui-là
petit l'heure des familles
c'est exactement un endroit où j'ai
trouvé le petit vélo dogues
donc là j'ai plutôt confiance
encore une tonne de plastique
de grâce
donc
à mouthe aussi
morte ou encore une selle de moto
salah est sympathique
bah
même piste
il
pas de grosses boules
je
je pense que ça
votre boule de pétanque
ayem gros truc
oh [ __ ] c'est pas moi [ __ ] c'est
super long le gars
et en bonus un style au sud de france
les produits made in
languedoc-roussillon région à les morts
et les gares où je dis pas le poids de
ce match droit chez le ferrailleur
aujourd'hui on est avec des abonnés pour
une partie de pêche
bizier toujours voilà au port on est
l'autre côté de l'endroit où on était
d'habitude on va voir ce qu'on va
trouver de beaux arts de vannes
mais ces deux champions courent on
voudra pas un grand mur d'amay grappa
maison à votre péché à yeggo approche un
peu
peut-être parce qu auteur
voilà quelle petite barrière qui pisse
surtout pas la première trouvaille on va
dire ouais
ouais on va la différence
les beaux lundis seront mauvais vivre
romeria rire est un coin facile ni vote
mais c'est possible
c'était vraiment une mini battant non
250 trucs et mais en fait différence
entre le oui
après le prix à une différence aussi un
bond à aucun impôt bon pot à être
bloquée manière dont ses amis les flics
eu comme ça voilà ça va du pont rouge
avec ça c'est rare
à vrai dire l'intérêt droite la
bouteille voilà peut-être d'obus non je
pensais sans ambages pas trop ce que
c'est
un juge a fait un truc comme ça je
pensais
c'est moi ouais
ah ouais les vieux pilonnent la whey
fois encore c'est pas une douche non non
ça c'est peut-être un truc de ouais
ouais ouais sauf que ces bouchers donc
non comme moi mais ça aurait pu aller
c'est plus un truc de bagnols tapis de
bagnols doit annoncer en fait elle du
cul c'est juste la vis derrière kita et
moi c'est pas la pêche à dénoncer la
pêche à la manche pas c'est quoi ça le
mini moteurs diesel du cube l'attend
ça c'est une bobine je crois va
nécessiter une bobine c'est une bobine
une bobine suis sûr ça j'ai déjà fait
plein de bons retours quittant sa jeune
garde
c'est la 3e journée quoi
amd jours sauf que vraiment que de la
merde alors erreur ce qu'on peut
attraper des trousseaux de clés
ok ouais c'est une branche
parce que
très bien corde
[Applaudissements]
viens
ma
un bon petit rideau de douche sympa
fargo s'est passé panneaux bizarre et
tordu ou pas what nice et la boule de
pétanque
qu'est ce que c'est ça au tiers et une
bonbonne de protoxyde d azote
donc je pense qu'on va y aller parce que
bon le spot s'étaient déjà faits restait
pas grand chose